The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So morning.
This is my fourth lecture
on differential equations,
that part of the course.
And I haven't said anything
about the textbook.
That's Differential
Equations and Linear Algebra.
I wrote it because so
many courses like this one
want to combine
those two topics.
They're the two major topics
of undergraduate math,
after calculus, the two major
directions, and the book
connects those two directions.
And I just wanted to give
you the website for lots
of things connected
with the book.
So it's the math website, dela
for differential equations
and linear algebra.
And so today is differential
equations, second order,
with a damping term, with
a first derivative term.
So that in many engineering
problems, those coefficients
A, B, C would have
the meaning of mass,
damping, and stiffness.
Mass, damping, and stiffness.
And physically, we know
what the mass comes from.
The stiffness comes from a
spring, as I drew before.
And traditionally we
describe the source
of damping as a dashpot.
I guess in my whole life
I've never seen a dashpot,
but maybe it's-- think of a
piston going up and down within
a cylinder of oil or
something, with resistance.
OK, so that's the
left-hand side.
Linear constant
coefficients still.
We don't have formulas,
it's not easy to see what's
happening when
things are varying,
when the equations non-linear,
so this is the starting place.
OK.
With some forcing.
So this is damped forced motion.
This is the ultimate
within linear equations.
OK.
And now, what's the forcing?
So now, always we solve
first for the null solution.
With no force, what are
the natural motions?
And we'll find a
formula for those.
Then the big one, the
special right-hand side
is always an exponential.
So this is going to be y is
going to be the null solution
yn, and we'll get
a formula for that.
This, the exponentials.
Always, the response to an
exponential is an exponential.
That's like the most important
fact in getting solutions.
So the response will
be some ye to the st
at the same frequency--
well, I say frequency.
If s is a real number that
would be a growth or a decay,
but very frequently s
is an imaginary number,
like last time.
And this is comes from a
rotation or an oscillation.
And then, the
complete picture comes
from being able to solve
it with an impulse.
So then y is the
impulse response,
which I write as g of t.
Let me introduce
just that letter g.
That stands for growth factor
in first order equations
stands for Green's
function, so that word Green
is getting in here, his name.
And it represents
the impulse response.
OK, one, two, three.
And then the point of doing this
one is that then we can do it,
then we can get a
formula for any f of t.
So this is the pattern
that we followed
for first order equations.
We followed it for
second order equations
that didn't have damping.
And now we're doing the
big one with damping.
So what's the
damping going to do?
What's going to be
effect of damping?
Say if I had a right side
of one, just a unit force?
The damping.
So I'll still have
oscillation-- you'll
see this-- I'll still
have oscillation,
but its amplitude damps out.
Like that like everything
we know, like something
swinging back and
forth, but friction
is it is eventually
damping out that motion.
So it'll be oscillating
with exponentially
decaying amplitude.
Let's find this solution.
OK.
How do we find
the null solution?
I've got constant
coefficients here.
So the nice, the right thing
to look at is exponentials.
In first order equations
it was e to the at.
Here, we'll have
to see what it is.
So I'm going to try
a particular-- I'm
going to look for the
right exponentials.
Certain exponentials
will be null solution.
Can I do it?
So I take that
equation and put in y
equal e to the st. Remember
now, I'm doing 0 here
so it's not the same s
as the right-hand side.
OK.
What happens if
I put in-- so I'm
looking for the null solution.
I'll try y equal e to
the st. Plug it in.
I get m.
Two derivatives gives me
s squared e to the st, b.
One derivative gives
me an s, e to the st,
and k gives me k e
to the st. And that's
supposed to equal to 0
for the null solution.
OK.
Have we made a good
guess at what will work?
Yes, because I can
cancel e to the st,
and I come to the most
important equation.
The equation that
governs everything
in this whole
lecture is ms squared
plus bs plus k equals 0.
That's called the characteristic
equation, or it has many names.
It's obviously the big deal.
It's the thing.
It's an equation for s, for
the special frequencies that
solve the null
equation with no force.
OK.
And how many values
of s do we expect?
Two.
So I expect solutions s1 and
s2, and then my null solution
is e to the s1t is
a null solution.
E to the s2t is another one.
My equation is linear.
I can multiply that
by any constant.
I can multiply this
And I can superimpose, i
can add, I can combine,
because I can do
linear algebra here.
This is the most important
operation in linear algebra,
multiply things by
constants and add.
That's called a
linear combination.
It's the basic operation
in linear algebra
and it's a basic operation
here, because we're
doing linear algebra
with functions.
Do you see that that's it?
We've got it, except we
should really write a formula
and draw some pictures
to show s1 and s2.
What would be the formula for
s1 and s2, to the two solutions?
We remember that from school,
it's the quadratic formula.
The two solutions to this.
Everybody remember this one?
Let's see if I do.
Does it start with-- a minus b.
And then there's going to be a
denominator that I'll remember,
which is 2a.
No.
I said a but I mean m.
2m.
And now this is plus or
minus-- what goes into here?
B squared minus 4ac.
The key quantity in this whole
business, b squared minus 4ac.
Ah, what is it?
Mk, thank you.
4mk.
Great.
And can I just remark, a
little remark about units.
B squared has the
same units as 4mk.
It has to or such a
formula would be crazy.
So we will see that
actually there's
something called the
damping ratio that
involves the ratio
of these guys.
OK, that's the formula.
But it's not like-- OK
it's got a square root,
and what's the point
of-- the thing we
have to remember with this
square root is that if it's
the square root of
a positive number
then we have a plus or
minus, ordinary real numbers.
If this thing is
negative, then what?
What's up if b squared
is smaller than 4mk?
So if b squared is-- if there's
not much damping, if it's
underdamped, b squared
would be smaller than 4mk.
And what then?
We've got a negative
number here.
When we take its square root
we have an imaginary number.
That's oscillation.
Under-damping is going
to show oscillation.
Let me draw this.
Let me draw that curve for
different choices of m, b,
and k.
This is a good picture to see.
So let me draw first of all
one that has b equals 0.
OK.
So there's a curve.
What I'm drawing
is, up on this curve
is this ms squared
plus bs plus k.
Ms squared and bs and k.
And here, this one is one
with no damping at all.
This is just s squared
plus 0 s plus 1.
That's what that curve is That's
the example we saw before.
Y double prime plus y.
Y double prime plus y equals 0.
This is coming from Y double
prime plus y equals 0.
This is pure oscillation.
OK.
Now let me bring
in some damping.
Now, as I bring in damping
the curve will move.
And it takes a little patience
to see where it moves.
Let me have a little
damping a little damping,
so s squared plus 1 s plus 1.
I think the curve--
so this is s here.
And it's a parabola.
Everything I draw
here is a parabola,
is just that different
parabolas come
from different choices of b.
So I think that
this choice, I think
it goes a little bit like that.
That's the next one.
It goes down a bit.
Now, let me do s
squared plus 2s plus 1.
Now, let's see, I really
should stop for a moment
and solve the equation, find the
roots for each of these guys.
And then I'm going to have
an s squared plus 3s plus 1.
So we're doing something very
straightforward, parabolas.
But it shows us the
different possibilities.
And we could give them names.
OK.
So I would call
this one undamped.
And what are the roots
of that equation?
S squared plus 0
s plus 1 equals 0.
What are the s1 and
s2 for that guy.
So the roots of s squared
plus 1 equals 0 are?
Stay with me here.
S squared plus 1
equals 0, that's
the equation that has roots.
STUDENT: I and minus i
PROFESSOR: I and minus i.
I and minus i.
So this is undamped.
S1 is i and s2 is minus i.
That's the pure oscillation.
Pure oscillation, that's
the case where b is 0 here,
I have a square root
of a negative number,
and it gives me
plus or minus 2i,
and then the 2s cancel
and I get plus or minus i.
So I can always go
back to this but I'll
try to choose numbers
that come out nicely.
Now, what happens
with some damping?
This guy.
What are the roots for this one?
Well, I better use this formula.
Now, I'm always keeping
m equal 1 and k equal 1,
in all those samples.
But now b has increased to 1.
So if b is 1, what do I have?
I have s is-- the
roots are minus 1,
plus or minus the square root--
And it's going to be just 2
down below.
What's in the square root,
the all important square root.
When m and k and b are all 1.
Just do the calculation
with me, so you see it.
It's negative?
STUDENT: Three.
PROFESSOR: Negative 3.
So what's the point there?
The point is, this is going to
be square root of 3i or minus
i.
We have oscillation at a
frequency square root of 3,
and we have decay
from s minus one-half.
The real part of this is
giving us the drop off.
We didn't have any drop
off at all in this case.
They were pure imaginary.
Now the s1 and s2 are
whatever I have a minus 1,
plus or minus square
root of 3i over 2.
Those are the roots.
All right, I'm
ready for this guy,
and it's particularly nice.
It's particularly nice.
What do you see for s
squared plus 2s plus 1?
When you see this parabola,
now b has moved up to 2.
What's up with that one?
It's going to be--
let's see-- that looks
like a perfect square to me.
Right, inside the
square root is 0.
Right, exactly.
Inside the square root, b
squared is 4, and 4mk is 4,
so I have 0 inside
this square root.
So now I have s equals minus
1 plus or minus 0 over 2.
That's when this was the
case, when b moved up to 2.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] minus 2.
PROFESSOR: I'm messing it up?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] equals
minus 2, plus or minus 0.
PROFESSOR: Minus
2 plus or minus 0.
Thank you.
So what do I have?
What are the roots of this guy?
Negative 1.
What's the other one?
A double root.
It's critical damping.
Critical damping--
it's not underdamped.
It's not overdamped.
It's right on the borderline.
And I see that, when you
first saw quadratics,
before anybody brought
up that awful formula,
you would have factored this
into s plus 1 squared equals 0,
and you would have discovered
that s was minus 1 twice.
A double root.
So the picture there would
be-- there's minus 1.
Yeah.
Everybody recognize that this,
we're hitting 0, height 0.
We're hitting 0 twice
at s equal minus 1.
So this is now the case.
This was b equal 0, no damping.
This was b equal
1, under-damping.
This is b equal 2, critical
damping, just on the border.
And what do you
think the s squared
plus 3s plus 1 is
going to look like.
Again, we can find it.
No, let me do the s squared
plus-- let me take b equal 3
and find the roots
and draw the picture.
If you're with, me that
picture and these formulas
tell you the difference
between these four cases.
So what do I get?
Minus 3 plus or minus the
square root of, 9 minus 4,
is 5, over 2.
So I have two negative roots.
I have decay.
I have decay at a fast
rate and a slow rate
but both are giving decay.
So the curve now is coming
down here and back up there,
and it hits there, and
it's got the two roots.
These two roots are x and x.
So these are s1 and s2.
Let me copy them over here.
S1 and s2 are minus
3 plus or minus
the square root of 5 over 2.
Yeah.
Real.
Real roots.
So this is two real roots.
This is a double real root.
This is two complex roots.
And this is two pure
imaginary roots.
The four possibilities.
The famous four.
OK.
And for me, that
picture is a-- so
this was the b equal 3
curve, more overdamped.
It's a little interesting
that overdamping
has this root that's
pretty near 0.
So overdamping doesn't mean
that you go to 0 real fast.
Actually, the one
that goes fastest to 0
is the critical damping.
Then, as b grows, one
root gets closer to 0,
so it's like slower
decay, and another root
is going off to fast decay.
I think you have
to know those guys,
because the physically
that's very important,
where's the damping.
But we've now found the
null solution completely.
The null solution
completely is--
let me write it again
here-- is anything times e
to the s1t and anything
times e to the s2t.
And where do those constants,
c1 and c2 get decided?
By the?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Initial conditions.
Right.
These two conditions
determine c1 and c2.
OK.
Are we good?
So the null solution has already
separated the different cases
that depend on how much damping.
I'm ready for number two.
Number two now.
OK.
So the idea is I now have a
forcing term, some frequency
e to the st. And I will
assume that it's not--
s not equal s1 or s2.
That's to make my life easy.
Just as last time, the
formulas will break down.
And I'll have to put
in something different
if there's resonance,
if the driving force is
at the same frequency
as a natural frequency.
In that case,
there's a resonance.
And the way you spot
a resonance formula
is there's an extra factor of t.
There's a growth of t.
Up here, we're seeing
no factors of t.
Over there in the
exponent, of course.
I mean, down below, there
would be a t times e to the st.
And the book does
that carefully.
I don't see that it has a
place in the very first lecture
on this topic.
OK.
So this is saying no resonance.
All right.
What's the solution then?
The solution is a
multiple of e to the st.
The input was e to the
st. The response is
a multiple of e to st, so
that's the frequency response.
Capital Y is telling
us the response to s.
And it's a very, very
important function.
It's called the
transfer function.
It's just the key to everything.
I probably say that
so often, that this
is the key to everything.
Well, it's partly
because I just have
one lecture to do a big part
of differential equations,
and it's got some key ideas.
And the first key
idea is s1 and s2.
And the second key idea
is Y. And let's go for it.
All right, so this is
the s1 and s2 picture.
I'll move that up, and
now, in the equation,
try Y e to the st.
We hope it works.
What is this?
I'm trying, this is my solution,
and it's a particular solution
now.
I got the null solution.
I've moved to a particular
And this is when the force is
e to the st. In other words,
I'll just say again, if we
have an exponential force,
try an exponential response.
1803 would call this the
exponential response formula.
So you could use
the word exponential
response, very appropriate.
You could use the word
frequency response.
That frequency response is
kind of the right word when
s is an imaginary number giving
an oscillation frequency.
OK, I'm going to plug that in.
So into the differential
equation, m.
Second derivative of that is s
squared Y e to the st, right?
That's m Y double prime.
The beauty of exponentials.
Take every derivative,
just brings down an s.
The next term.
What's the next term?
Maybe do it with
me, do it for me.
What happens when I plug in this
as Y into b, so there'll be a b
Y prime.
So what's Y prime?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: s, Y, this
constant, e to the st.
And then the final term
is k times this Y itself,
no derivative, so it's
just Y e to the st,
and that's matching e to
the st. That's the force.
This is f.
F, this is an exponential force.
Of course, I could and
should have a constant here
to give me the units of force.
Let me just keep
the formula as clean
as possible by taking
units, so that's one.
OK what do I do?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I cancel.
The nice part of 287 is
canceling e to the st.
That's the most fun you get.
And now, I have Y's on the left.
So Y is-- can I see what Y is?
Y is this 1, divided by
the coefficient of Y.
And what's the coefficient of Y?
We know it.
We've seen that coefficient.
Y on the left is multiplied by
ms squared plus bs plus k ms
squared, again, ms
squared, bs, and k.
Multiplying Y, I divide by
that, so I put it down here.
Ms squared plus bs plus k.
And because s is not one
of the roots, that's not 0,
so we're golden.
That problem took five minutes.
The null solution
took half an hour.
The exponential
response is clear.
And you can see
what it would be.
And let's give it a name.
This is the transfer function.
Widely used name.
Other names could be
given but that's the best.
So it's a function of s.
It's a function of s.
And so, again, when
f is e to the st,
it sort of transfers the
input into the output.
That's the way I think
of the transfer function.
Here is the input.
The output is just multiplied
by the transfer function.
And the transfer function is
just that nice expression.
Just that nice expression.
So we are golden
for a frequency,
for a linear equation with an
exponential forcing function.
What would be another example?
I'm using mass,
dashpot, spring here.
If this was in
electrical engineering,
what three things would I be
using instead of mass, dashpot,
spring.
The three guys would be?
What would correspond
to the dashpot?
So can I just draw
here a little--
let me put on a
low voltage and put
on something that does this,
and then something like this.
And then there's
something like this.
And give me a break, tell
me what these things are.
This guy is?
STUDENT: Inductor.
PROFESSOR: An inductor.
This guy is a?
STUDENT: Resistor.
PROFESSOR: Resistor.
Now that's the one
that's like damping.
This resistor here
is like damping.
Like the damping
term, or maybe 1/b.
I'm not getting its
units right because I
haven't got any
equation here at all.
Resisting is-- there's
friction in that resistor.
It burns up heat.
And similarly, the
dashpot slows things down.
And then this guy is a--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Capacitor, right.
In other words, you can do
the mechanical application
and the electrical application
with exactly the same ideas,
just a change of letter, and
of course, different units,
but same problem.
OK, so that's a comment
that you've seen before.
What else do I
want to comment on?
Because this example was
really so straightforward.
I think what I want
to mention, and this
is important, is that this
is the central starting
point for the Laplace transform.
So I can't do Laplace transforms
all today by any means,
and so Professor Fry will talk
about the Laplace transform
next week.
But what is the point of
the Laplace transform?
The point of the
Laplace transform
is to get your money's worth
out of the simple formula
for exponentials.
Having an exponential there
turns the whole differential
equation problem into
an algebra problem.
We just have
quadratic equations.
We just have a division
by a quadratic.
That's the great thing
about the Laplace transform.
It turns the t domain,
the time domain,
where we have exponentials,
into the s domain,
the exponent domain,
the frequency domain,
where we just have quadratics.
And then first order
equation's just linear.
And we can even get from
second order of the quadratic
to linear, because I
can factor that guy.
If I factor into s minus
s1 times s minus s2,
I've two linear pieces.
And that's the first step
in the Laplace transform,
in the algebra.
So all of the algebra
in the Laplace transform
is this algebra for e to the st.
And then the job of the
Laplace transform-- and this
is the tricky part.
So let me even take a
little board space on that.
So this is like a
heads up for next week.
So the Laplace transform.
OK.
So for any forcing
function, f of t.
That's the thing
that we're going
to take the Laplace
transform of and the response
and its response, y of t.
OK.
So here's the idea of
transforms in general.
I choose some terrific
functions like exponentials.
So I want to convert my
problem to exponentials.
e to the st for all s, s between
let's say 0 and infinity.
So what do I do?
I take my function,
and I figure out
how much of every
exponential is in it.
That's the Laplace transform.
I take my function
f of t, and I go
to what you'll see next
week, its Laplace transform.
Let me call it capital F
of s, or it's sometimes
written the Laplace
transform of F of s.
Something like that.
I'm not going to do that.
I'm not going there.
So F of s is like the amount
of a particular exponential
in my function.
If my function is just the
sum of two exponentials,
then the Laplace transform
just is a big bump on one
and a big bump on the other.
But most functions, like
some forcing function,
has some e to the st is for
all for a whole range of s.
So I figure out how
much of this is.
OK now second step.
Using linearity, I
can solve the problem
for when the right
hand side is just that.
Then solve for
right hand side, F
of s, e to the st. Solve
for each frequency,
each s separately.
And what does that mean?
That means just
dividing by this.
So this was the easy step.
So this is step one, is
take the Laplace transform.
The Laplace transform tells you
how much of each exponential
is in it.
Now step two is a cinch.
Step two is a cinch.
I just multiply by
the transfer function.
I divide by this, bs plus k.
And now, what's step three.
Step three, I have the solution
for each separate exponential,
but I've got a whole
lots of exponentials,
so I have to do an
inverse Laplace transform,
add up, figure out what function
has this Laplace transform.
And that's often the place
where the algebra gets harder.
In principle, we can
do it for any F of t.
We can take its
Laplace transform,
we can solve for each
frequency in the transform,
we can assemble
them all together.
That's the inverse
Laplace transform,
so this is the inverse Laplace
to get the solution y of t.
So this is really the Laplace
transform of the solution,
and we have to get back
to the solution itself.
Can I just let you
think about those ideas?
I'm not up to describing
the algebra here.
The point is the
Laplace transform
takes this into
separate exponentials.
Each of those right hand
sides is simple algebra,
divide by that.
And then you have
the job of okay,
what function has this Laplace
transform, to go backwards.
And that's usually
the hard part.
So people make tables
of Laplace transforms.
Everybody remembers the Laplace
transforms of a few functions.
You could say that
those few functions are
the golden functions of
differential equations.
The golden functions of
differential equations
are the ones where you know
their Laplace transform
and you can go back
and forth easily.
And what are those
golden functions?
Well, you might
guess exponentials,
simple polynomials,
1 t, t squared.
You can do Laplace
transform for those.
What else do you
think would be nice?
Cosine and sine.
And you could multiply
those together.
We could deal with
t times cosine t.
So a little bit different.
But having said that,
the reality is I've
given you the whole
list of nice functions.
Those functions show up
in every simple method
for solving equations.
There's a method called
undetermined coefficients
and what does it amount to?
I'm sorry, I don't have
time to say it this morning,
but it can come later.
Undetermined.
It just means if
the right hand side
is one of these
nice guys-- shall
I write down again
the golden functions?
e to the st is like
the platinum function.
And then some golden functions
are like t and t squared
and so on.
Of course, when we get that,
we're close to cosine omega t,
and sine omega t.
All these guys, their
Laplace transforms are nice.
We can deal with
them completely.
Or multiply any
of those together.
And when the right hand side is
one of these golden functions,
you can write down the answer.
We've focused on this one
because it's the platinum one.
And we did these two
too, because they
come from s equal i omega.
And then these guys are
a little bit of juice.
But that's it.
I'm sorry the list isn't longer.
It'd be nice to
have--and of course,
people for centuries have
worked with the next hardest
functions.
You know, the silver functions.
Famous functions have names
like Bessel's function
or Legendre's function.
Others where you
can get pretty far.
Those are the best.
Then you have the famous ones
where you get pretty far,
in the web has the
Laplace transforms,
and then you get the
general function, F of t.
Oh, could you get
anywhere with delta of t?
Oh, yes.
Does it belong on the
list of golden functions?
Yes, it does.
I almost forgot it,
and it's like-- I'll
call it-- Yeah, delta of t.
Yeah, that's a beauty.
That's a beauty.
The Laplace transform
of delta of t
happens to come out 1 over s.
You can't ask for
more than that.
Or maybe it's one.
Yeah, it's probably one.
Yeah, the Laplace
transform of that is one.
Yeah.
It's got all exponentials
in sort of, you could say,
equal amounts.
OK.
So that's some thoughts about
that about Laplace transforms,
just sort of the big picture
that takes the differential
equation, turns it into
an algebra problem,
and then at the end,
you have to get back,
and that's the part
that's not always doable.
OK.
So what's left for
today is this guy.
Now this one now.
Have I got to that point?
So this will be the final
ideas in this course,
this four unit core elective.
What is the impulse response
when there's damping?
What's the impulse response
OK.
So that means that
I would really
like to solve m
y double prime, b
y prime, k Y equals an
impulse, delta of t.
Because if I can solve this,
then I can solve everything.
And I can solve this.
It turns out to be easy.
Now why is it easy?
You might think, my gosh, we've
got second order equations
here, we've got a delta
function there, where do we go?
And so my advice is go this way.
The solution to
that is the same.
This with y of 0 equals 0
and y prime of 0 equal 0.
So you have a spring, so again
we have a spring with a mass.
And that spring is in a damper.
So can I just, without
knowing what I'm doing,
draw a damper around it.
So the idea is I'm striking
that mass at time 0.
Striking that mass at time 0.
What happens?
What happens immediately?
And then I don't touch it again.
I strike it and that's it.
I've set off, and what have
I-- so my point is this
has the same solution as m y
double prime plus b y prime.
And Ky equals 0.
Nothing happens beyond time 0.
But what are y of 0-- Well,
let me give this a letter g,
just to emphasize it's special
and deserves its own name.
So now, what is the
starting position
and the starting velocity
for this picture?
So I'm saying that the y here
is the same as the g there.
And really if you see
it physically then
you see it best.
So again, at the
instant t equals 0,
I'm hitting that mass
with a unit impulse.
So what is the position
of that mass, instantly
after I've hit it?
STUDENT: 0.
PROFESSOR: Still 0.
Good for you.
And what is the velocity
of that mass instantly
after I've hit it?
STUDENT: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1 is essentially
the right answer.
1 is the right answer.
But the way I've set it up
is, there is an m there.
If I put an m there,
which would be nicer,
then the answer would be 1.
But the way I've written
it here, I have an m there,
and I haven't fixed the units.
So that turns out to
give me a 1/m there.
I could explain why
it's a 1/m, but let me
just for the moment
say it's my fault.
It's because I didn't get any
units right that we have 1/m.
No big deal.
But now, what's good here?
What's good?
This was a problem with a
mysterious delta function.
This is a problem with 0.
And the only price we're
paying is the impulse
gave the mass a little velocity.
And you can imagine
that the velocity gives
it is 1/m because the strike
didn't tell us about that.
So what I'm saying is we can
solve that equation for g.
We can find g, and
in fact, we have.
So this really brings
the lecture full circle.
What do I have here?
I have a null solution.
So this g here is
a null solution.
So what form does it have?
What can you tell
me about g of t?
And it's the same as y of t.
So y is the same as g, and
what's the form for it?
Yes?
Tell me?
I'm taking it back
to the very beginning
of the lecture where
I solved it with a 0.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: C1, thanks.
PROFESSOR: e to the?
C1, e to the s1, t, the two
s's, s1 and s2, the special two
s's, the special roots
of the key equation.
That equation gives us s1
and s2, by this formula,
or in a homework
or an exam problem,
we hope that it would
come out easily.
So this is that part of it.
What's the rest of it?
C2 e to the s2 t.
The impulse response is the
particular null solution
that starts with a shot,
starts with an impulse,
starts with a strike.
OK.
So I just have to
find c1 and c2 here.
All right?
We've come back to
the basic problem
in differential equations.
We've got the solution.
We've got two constants.
We've got two equations.
We just plug that function
into that equation.
It gives us one
fact about c1, c2.
This gives us the second fact.
We solve them.
Why don't I just
write down the answer?
It turns out to
be e to the s1 t,
and the other guy will come
in with an opposite sign e
to the s2t over s1 minus s2.
I think that gives us the c's.
Oh, there'd be an m.
There'd be an m
times this, because
of my messing with units.
So can we just check?
At t equals 0, what
do I get out of this?
STUDENT: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0.
What I'm supposed to.
What's the derivative
at t equals 0?
The derivative at t
equals 0, this derivative
is going to bring down an s1.
The derivative here
will bring down an s2.
At t equals 0 the
exponentials will all
be one so I'll just have
the s1 minus the s2.
It'll cancel that and
it'll be 1 over m.
So this is the neat formula
for the impulse response.
That's the neat formula
And then why-- can I use this
little corner of the board?
Why do I want that
impulse response?
What can I use it for?
It gives me the answer,
not just for the impulse
but for everything.
The particular solution
is for any forces, force,
I multiply by whatever the--
let me write the formula
and I'll show you what it says.
Yes, there is the formula.
I'm sorry it's squeezed.
But really, the
goal here was simply
to get a handle on what
is the response to any f.
And again, I look
at that this way.
F of s is the input at time s.
G is the growth factor over the
remaining time up until time t.
So Y at time t, I take all
the inputs up to time t,
And each input gets multiplied
by its growth factor.
It was e to the a, t minus s
in the first order equation.
Now we've got two exponentials.
But that's the solution
of the general problem.
So we have now in one
lecture completed a solution
to the second order constant
coefficient differential
equation.
Right.
Yeah.
By finding the impulse response.
Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
would we still
be able to [INAUDIBLE]
if s1 is equal to s2?
PROFESSOR: Ah, if s1 equals s2.
That's the case where
formulas need a patch.
They need a patch.
If s1 equals s2, what
do you think happens?
If s1 equal s2, everybody
sees, I have 0/0.
And so this is like
a technical question
that I wasn't going
to ask myself.
You asked it.
You're responsible.
What do we do for 0/0?
What did you learn in calculus?
Who's the crazy guy who figured
out how to deal with 0/0?
In a way, calculus is
all about 0/0, right?
Delta y over delta x,
they're both headed to 0.
And suppose you
have-- let me take
the most famous example of 0/0.
It's like sine x over
x, as x goes to 0.
So x going to 0.
Sine x goes to 0, x goes to 0.
What's the answer, by the way?
What happens to that
ratio as x goes to 0?
This is maybe the
most famous example.
Sine x over x, when x gets
very small, is close to?
STUDENT: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1, thanks.
And now just help me out
with the name of the guy.
It's a crazy spelling
name, and do you remember?
L'Hopital.
Everybody despises him.
Probably hi friends
despised him.
But anyway, L'Hopital says
in a situation like that,
when you're going to
0/0, you're allowed
to do something
a little strange.
You're allowed to take
the derivative of the top,
so it has the same limit.
Instead of looking
at this 0/0, you
can take the derivative
of the top, cos x,
divided by the derivative
of the bottom, 1.
And now you can let x go to 0,
and you get the right answer.
So this gave a 0/0.
Unclear.
Fuzzy.
This gives-- what's
the right answer then?
Just tell me again.
When x goes to 0 this becomes?
STUDENT: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1.
Right.
So that's L'Hopital.
So that's what I
would have to do here.
I would take the
derivative of this,
and the derivative of this--
the only sort of tricky part
is it's the s derivative.
It's s1 going to s2.
Let me just tell you the result.
Since you asked.
A factor t comes out.
It's t e to the s1, or s1 is the
same as s2, divided by the m.
It actually looks simpler.
There's only one.
This is in the case s1 equal s2.
So s1 is the same as s2.
I just chose s1.
Yeah.
L'Hopital gives
a simpler answer.
And it's got this suspicious
and recognizable factor t.
That came from L'Hopital.
OK, I won't do that stiff.
So let me say again, we've
now done the second order
constant coefficient
equation I do just
have 10 minutes of
something to make it better.
And that is that the famous
quadratic formula for s,
for s1 and s2 is not beautiful.
It's correct.
But it's a little bit of a mess.
You've got three things, b
and m and k playing around.
And we saw in this picture,
we saw all the differences.
I guess in this example
I kept m1 and I kept k1,
and I increased b.
I could do other examples
where I increase the k,
I make it stiffer and stiffer.
All these examples.
And engineers have
worked for 100 years
to see, out of this formula what
are the important parameters,
what are the important
numbers, and hopefully,
where possible dimensionless.
So I just want to-
the final minutes
would be-- back to high school--
playing with this formula,
to get better numbers in there.
May I do that?
I just think,
because then you'll
see-- I learned this, actually,
so this is like something math
professors have no reason to do.
Look at that.
That's the formula.
End of story.
But the Web, 1803
website, has a class
in which Professor Miller
from the math department
was teaching this subject,
doing these, exactly these,
but also Professor
Vandiver from Engineering
was putting in his suggestion
of what are the good parameters?
What are the parameters
that engineers look at?
So that would be
my final comment,
and I won't do it as well
as Professor Vandiver did.
But can I just
take that-- let me
erase these two
special examples,
and look at this question.
Again, the book will do it.
So one nice-- b/2m is a pretty
natural parameter to use.
Let me introduce
that as one of them.
I'm going to, by taking ratios
like b/2m, let me call that p.
Let me call b/2m.
So that's a ratio
of damping to mass.
And then this has got
to come out simpler.
What does that come out?
If you'll allow me, I'm
going to open the book
so I don't write the
wrong thing here.
This is in the book, on page 99.
The title is Better
Formulas for s1 and s2.
Better Formulas for s1 and s2.
And here's my first
better formula.
You can see that I get a minus
b plus or minus the square root
of something.
And that something will
turn out to be p squared.
And then it'll be
a minus something.
And that something
will turn out to be
the natural frequency squared.
Isn't that nice?
So what's the natural frequency?
Somehow, the natural frequency's
coming in from this and this?
And just remind me what
that second parameter is,
omega n squared, the
natural frequency
of oscillation with no damping.
Tell me again what
that is, because that
was the fundamental
ratio from last time.
It's central to
all of engineering.
It's?
STUDENT: k/m.
PROFESSOR: k/m.
Thanks, k/m.
So I believe-- and
maybe Professor Fry
could make this assignment
a homework question,
which is just algebra question.
Everybody sees that I
have a minus p here.
And with a little care you get
p squared, which is quite nice.
Which is quite nice.
And so we see that the
decision between overdamping--
remember now?
Overdamping is when you damped
so much that this became
negative and you got an
imaginary number in there.
Underdamping, it's
still positive.
Overdamping, it's negative.
And so really that separation
between overdamping
and underdamping is the
ratio of p to omega n.
P to omega n is
the damping ratio.
I think.
There may be a factor too.
Let me try to-- everybody
sees that's the battle
between these, if you
accept that formula,
and if it's in the book
it's got to be right.
OK.
And so the damping
ratio is just that.
That's the damping ratio.
Now that's called zeta.
The Greek letter zeta.
I'm not Greek and not
good writing zeta.
So I have unilaterally decided
to use a capital zeta, which
is a Z. Zeta is the Greek letter
for Z. I could try to write it
but you wouldn't be impressed.
So it's that damping ratio.
So now what does this mean?
Z smaller than 1, z equal
to 1, c greater than 1?
Tell me what those-- obviously,
when it's smaller than 1,
p is smaller than omega n.
Yeah, so what's going on here?
Which one is underdamping,
which one is critical
damping, which one
is overdamping?
Because there's no
difficult stuff here.
We're coasting in
the last minutes
here by just choosing words and
notation that have turned out
over a century to be more
revealing than b squared
minus 4mk, and this Z.
So z less than 1 will be what?
Z less than 1 will be
p smaller than omega n.
p smaller than this.
What's the story
on that case then?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That is underdamping,
I guess. p small has to go.
p is like b, the damping.
And small damping
is underdamping.
So this is underdamp.
Underdamp.
And that's the
case, in which we're
going to have some
imaginary stuff.
We're going to have
some oscillation
with the decay
coming from there.
Now, what about z equal to 1?
z equal to 1 means
p equals omega m,
so that equals that so
it's a big 0 in there.
What case is that?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Critical damping.
It's this case in that picture.
It's that case with a
double 0, equal s's.
Formulas that have to
take account of that, this
is critical.
And then finally, z
greater than 1 is what?
Overdamped.
Overdamping.
Z bigger than 1 means p is big.
P big means b is big, damping
is big, it's overdamped.
Overdamped.
So we've got it down to one
parameter, the damping ratio,
to tell us these things.
Rather than previously
we had to say
is b squared smaller than 4mk?
Is it equal to 4mk?
Is it bigger than 4mk?
Now we've got those words
down to a single number z.
And let me just write next to
us here that the z turns out
to be the ratio of the
damping to-- I think
it's right-- it's
the damping divided
by the square root
of 4mk, I think.
Can I just put a
question mark there.
You couldn't mess around
with the letters p and z.
But to get some variation
from some other,
but the point is, you
see how much cleaner that
is compared to this?
You're directly comparing
that number to that number.
And that ratio is that number.
Yeah.
So all the formulas
come out nicely.
Yeah, the formulas
And I guess what we see
here-- final comment-- what
we see here is what
is the frequency
of underdamped oscillations.
So I want to be in
this underdamping case
where there is oscillation.
There is an imaginary
number coming out of that.
But there's also a real number.
Is the frequency of underdamped
oscillation the same
as omega m, the
natural frequency?
No.
The frequency of that
number-- so final comment,
let me put it just here.
I would like this whole thing
to be i, to give me oscillation,
times omega d, the
damped frequency.
And let me just
say what that is.
So omega d, the
damped frequency,
squared, is this omega
natural frequency
squared minus the p squared.
If I had longer and we didn't
have blackboards already full
of formulas, I
could-- it's the thing
whose square root
we're taking here.
So this is minus p plus
or minus i, omega damped.
Omega damped is
this square root.
There, we succeeded to
fit in the better ratios,
the good quantities to look at.
So again, the good
quantities to look at
are p, z, the damping ratio,
omega d the damped frequency.
I think in a first
lecture you could say,
well, we already had
correct formulas,
we should just leave it there,
and that's absolutely true,
but anyway, this is what-- these
are the letters people have
introduced to make
the formulas easier
to understand in an
engineering problem.
OK.
I'm all done except
for questions.
Yes?
Don't ask me about
resonance again.
Yes, OK.
Yes?
STUDENT: In the case of where
we have the delta function, what
is the velocity [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: What is the what?
STUDENT: Why is the velocity
equal to [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: A-ha.
Okay.
You're right on the ball.
The question is where
did this come from.
Where did that come from?
Can I tell you?
So if I integrate
everything here,
if I take the integral
of everything,
between 0, a little bit left
of 0-- can I call that 0 minus?
Just a little bit left of 0.
This is crazy.
No math professor or
whatever should ever do this.
To a little bit right of
0, just a real short time.
So what am I going to call
a little bit right of 0?
0 plus.
OK now what is that integral?
Between a little left of
0 and a little right of 0,
you know what the integral
of the delta function is.
It is?
STUDENT: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1.
Good.
Now, what are these
ridiculous things?
Well, y is not changing
in this tiny, tiny time.
So this is something,
it's not getting big.
I'm integrating it over
this tiny little time.
It's nothing.
Forget it.
Similarly here, y prime,
the velocity is not
climbing to infinity.
There's no-- and
I'm just integrating
over this infinitesimal
little time.
Nothing here.
So this term has to be
responsible for the 1.
And now you can tell me the
integral of m y double prime.
What's the integral
of m y prime?
STUDENT: m y prime
PROFESSOR: m y prime.
So m y prime plus, at 0 plus,
minus m y prime at 0 minus.
But at 0 minus, it's 0.
You see what's happening?
And on the right
side I'm getting a 1.
This is-- no person who had any
skill with a blackboard would
allow this to happen.
But that happened.
OK.
So these lower order
terms are typical of math.
Lower order terms in
the limit, forget them.
This is the top term, and it
has to have something there,
because it has to balance the 1.
And what it has is
the jump in y prime.
So this is the instant
jump in y prime
in velocity, is times m gives 1.
So the instant jump jumped
us from 0 to 1 over m.
That's where I came from.
Well, that was a good question,
and a kind of crazy answer
but there it is.
OK, so we've got a mention
of the Laplace transform
as the algebra tool
that works when you're
staying with exponentials
and nice functions.
And you'll see more of that.
So it's a frequently used tool
to turn problems into algebra.